ven estas algas hicieron un viaje a la
estación espacial internacional
ella también quiere llegar lejos con tan
sólo 40 años anna lenna barbú que espera
ser la primera canciller ecologista de
alemania con muchos objetivos en su
campaña política
ryan somos la segunda fuerza de
oposición en el país desde hace dos años
y es como una competición deportiva hay
un favorito y un aspirante así que
estamos haciendo todo lo posible en esta
campaña para renovar el gobierno con
nuestro contenido y nuestra gente
la que fue campeona trampolinistas sabe
lo que es competir fue en postdam donde
aprendió a hacer política y ascendió
constantemente dentro del partido en
menos de 10 años esta foto es un poco
más antigua se tomó cuando ambos
acabábamos de ser elegidos benjamin
raich un viejo aliado suyo en postdam
está convencido de que con barbour los
verdes nunca han estado tan cerca del
poder para buques la primera mujer
ecologista que aspira la cancillería no
obstante su campaña pasó por un mal
momento debido a acusaciones de plagio y
a un supuesto olvido en la declaración
de miles de euros ahora sólo una minoría
de votantes cree que sería una buena
canciller los verdes están en la
oposición y es ahí donde deben quedarse
sí a tener a los verdes en un gobierno
de coalición pero no como socio
principal pero debido a la grave crisis
climática algunos verdes aún mantienen
la esperanza esta profesora jubilada
participa en su primera campaña
electoral y los tutoriales tenemos que
darlo todo para conseguir la cancillería
si acabamos siendo el socio menor de un
gobierno tendremos que hacer todo tipo
de compromisos justo eso vaticina las
encuestas tras su breve meteórico
ascenso lo mejor a lo que puede aspirar
a anna-lena actualmente es a liderar a
los verdes como un socio menor de un
gobierno de coalición